you love to spoof soap operas
yeah sure you had a soap opera spoof
that you did it was extremely popular
and as the stomach turn has the stomach
turns and what's funny is that I learned
later on that one of the reasons that
you guys spook them so much is that you
yourself were in real life obsessed with
SOPA I was only one all my children yeah
and I used to watch that I written
religiously right and so this one summer
my kids were little and my husband and I
were going to go to Europe so I asked a
friend to please send me every week to
the hotels at where we were going to be
every Friday send me a telegram telling
me what's going on in Pine Valley right
this is this is long before the days of
like let's download it on App you guys
you got to get someone to send you a
telegram explaining what happened that
weekend yourself opera so we were in
London I got that telegram for that
Friday then we were going to Paris I got
another telegram there then we were then
we went to Italy and we were Lake Como
and we were visiting some friends who
lived there and we got there late and we
were tired and the kids and we all went
to bed and around two o'clock in the
morning there was a knock on the door
and I opened the door and there were my
friends standing there that were in
their robes and the manager of the hotel
he had this tone and he was shaking and
I said what is it and he said we got
this telegram and I read it that Erica
hasn't come out of her coma yet
[Applause]
Mona is on trial for murder I start I
mean on and on and on all yeah yeah yeah
happening in Pine Valley I started to
laugh so hard that I was going they
thought I was crying yeah what he
obviously thought life in America was
really going on in this woman's life